every summer my family and I travel
across the world 3,000 miles away to the
culturally diverse country of India now
India is a country infamous for
scorching heat and humidity for me the
only relief from this heat is to drink
plenty of water
now while in India my parents always
remind me to only drink boiled or
bottled water because unlike here in
America where I can just turn on a tap
and easily get clean potable water in
India the water is often contaminated so
my parents have to make sure that the
water we drink is safe however I soon
realized that not everyone is fortunate
enough to enjoy the clean water we did
outside my grandparents house in the
busy streets of India I saw people
standing in long lines under the hot Sun
filling buckets with water from a tap I
even thought children who looked the
same age as me filling up these clear
plastic bottles with dirty water from
streams on the roadside watching these
kids forced to drink water that I felt
was too dirty to touch changed my
perspective on the world this
unacceptable social injustice compelled
me to want to find a solution to our
world's clean water problem I wanted to
know why these kids laughed water a
substance that is essential for life and
I learned that we are facing a global
water crisis now this may seem
surprising as 75 percent of our planet
is covered in water but only 2.5 percent
of that is fresh water and less than 1%
of Earth's fresh water supply is
available for human consumption with
rising populations industrial
development and economic growth
our demand for clean water is increasing
yet our freshwater resources are rapidly
depleting according to the World Health
Organization 660 million people in our
world lack access to a clean water
source lack of access to clean water is
a leading cause of death in children
under the age of five in developing
countries and UNICEF estimates that
3,000 children die every day from a
water related disease so after returning
home one summer in eighth grade I
decided that I wanted to combine my
passion for solving the global water
crisis with my interest in science so I
decided that the best thing to do would
be to convert my garage into a
laboratory actually at first I converted
my kitchen into a laboratory but my
parents they don't really approve and
kick me out I also read a lot of journal
papers on water related research and I
learned that currently in developing
countries something called
solar disinfection or sodus is used to
purify water sodas in sodas clear
plastic bottles are filled with
contaminated water and then exposed to
sunlight for six to eight hours the UV
radiation from the Sun destroys the DNA
of these harmful pathogens and
decontaminates the water
now while soda is really easy to use and
energy efficient as it only uses solar
energy it's really slow as it can take
up to two days when it's cloudy so in
order to make the sodus process faster
this new method called photocatalysis
has recently been used so what exactly
is this photocatalysis let's break it
down photo means from the Sun and a
catalyst is something that speeds up a
reaction
so what photocatalysis is doing is it's
just speeding up the solar disinfection
process when sunlight comes in and
strikes the photo catalysts like tio2 or
titanium dioxide
it creates these really reactive oxygen
species like super oxides hydrogen
peroxide and hydroxyl radicals these
reactive oxygen species are able to
remove bacteria and organics and a whole
lot of contaminants from drinking water
but unfortunately there are several
disadvantages to the way photocatalytic
sodus is currently deployed see what
they do is they take the clear plastic
bottles and they coat the inside with
this photocatalytic coating but photo
catalysts like titanium dioxide are
actually commonly used in sunscreens to
block UV radiation so when they're
coated on the inside of these bottles
they're actually blocking some of the UV
radiation and diminishing the efficiency
of the process
also these photocatalytic coatings are
not tightly bound to the plastic bottle
which means they wash off and people end
up drinking the catalyst while tio2 is
safe and inert it's really inefficient
if you keep drinking the catalyst
because then you have to continue to
replenish it even after a few uses so my
goal was to overcome the disadvantages
of these current treatment methods and
create a safe sustainable cost-effective
and eco-friendly method of purifying
water what started off as an
eighth-grade science-fair project is now
my photocatalytic composite for water
purification the composite combines
titanium dioxide with cement the cement
like composite can be formed into
several different shapes which results
in an extremely versatile range of
deployment methods for example you could
create a rod that can easily be placed
inside water bottles for individual use
or you can create a porous filter that
can filter water for families
you can even coat the inside of an
existing water tank to purify larger
amounts of water for communities over a
longer period of time now over the
course of this my journey hasn't really
been easy you know I didn't have access
to a sophisticated laboratory
I was 14 years old when I just started
and but I didn't let my age deter me in
my interest in pursuing scientific
research and wanting to solve the global
water crisis sea water isn't just the
universal solvent water is a universal
human right and for that reason I'm
continuing to work on the science fair
project from 2012 to bring it from the
laboratory into the real world and this
summer I founded catalyst for world
water a social enterprise aimed at
catalyzing solutions to the global water
crisis alone a single drop of water
can't do much but when many drops come
together they can sustain life on our
planet just as water drops come together
to form oceans I believe that we all
must come together when tackling this
global problem thank you thank you